she's been talking about it most of her
political career
german chancellor angela mackel is no
stranger to the science of climate
change
[Applause]
but this summer climate change became a
reality in germany itself flash flooding
killed more than 200 people and caused
billions of euros worth of damage
as mecca visited the devastation she
linked the floods to global warming and
admitted germany would have to become
far more ambitious
[Music]
has been in power for 16 years and there
she was in her final months in office at
the scene of the disaster urging swifter
action it sounded like an impassioned
plea
but what does that message say about her
responsibility for climate policy over
the past two decades and germany's
responsibility as a leading
industrialized nation
angela merkel
is
she has an incredibly mixed record on
climate change on climate policy
and
if you just look at the end numbers if
you just look at the co2 that germany is
admitted to
then
i think that should be the dominant
narrative
the reality is we've seen merkel take
very different approaches to climate
policy let's have a look at the various
faces we've seen three chancellors three
paths
three sets of results
the diplomatic leader who persuaded her
global counterparts to promise climate
action
the chancellor beholden to her country's
powerful car companies and business
interests
and a crisis manager trying to catch up
on protecting the climate as the clock
ticks down on her time in office
[Music]
this was angela mackel's first major
climate moment as chancellor she took
her environment minister to the ice
sheets in greenland on the front
[Music]
this message wasn't new from merkel back
in the 90s she served as environment
minister
as a scientist it was a role she
relished and one that helped put her on
the political map
in 1995 merkel hosted the first un
climate conference in berlin getting
fellow environment ministers from around
the world to work together
she carried that climate momentum into
her first term as chancellor
she used the g8 meeting in germany for
two important steps
getting industrialized nations to commit
to cutting global co2 emissions in half
by 2050
and to agree that climate change is
man-made
these were significant achievements
progress on a global level and this is
when german media started calling angela
merkel the climate chancellor on the
international stage i think it is fair
to say particularly in the rich world
that merkel was a climate chance that
she brought something new to these
discussions and she helped convince some
of the
what i think is like george w bush
merkel was keen to focus on climate at
home in germany too
she ditched a previous government's
plans to close nuclear power plants and
decided to keep them running
nuclear energy is low carbon so it would
help the country reach its emissions
targets
but in 2011 a catastrophe on the other
side of the world changed her mind
in japan a tsunami hit the fukushima
nuclear power plant and caused a
meltdown
in germany merkel made a remarkable
policy turn around
[Music]
this was a big transition merkel went
from keeping nuclear power plants open
in order to cut carbon emissions to
shutting them down because of fukushima
and on top of that she launched a new
plan
the energy venda or energy transition
this was a road map to supply the entire
country with 100 renewable energy
and this was the chancellor reacting to
events at a moment of opportunity
um adventure their politicians lurking
merkel's government introduced a scheme
to pay anyone individuals or companies
for producing renewable energy and
feeding it into the electricity grid
that helped create a boom in solar power
it became one of the cheapest energy
sources worldwide
[Music]
but there were global setbacks at the
copenhagen summit in 2009 merkel and
world leaders pushed for an agreement on
stricter emissions targets and failed
one of a row of disappointments for
developing nations looking to wealthy
nations like germany to lead
is this one of those countries
um in the global notes that i meet
the biggest
um they are one of those countries that
are responsible for the biggest mission
and we also are expecting the fact that
there should be leadership that comes
out from that area because um developing
countries
that can provide the tools that we
for us to see that we attain the climate
justice that we need
and then a different crisis took over
the spotlight you might remember the
crippling eurozone debt crisis leaders
made saving economies their top priority
and it became clear how powerful the
forces driving the german economy really
were
mercedes volkswagen bmw
global names industry giants crucial to
the german economy
cars give germany a robust domestic
manufacturing base and a mighty export
balance sheet
german car companies and suppliers
employed more than 800 000 people in
2019
and posted earnings of 436 billion euros
they are also some of the biggest
political cross-party donors in the
country
mackel like all chancellors before her
had to take their needs into
consideration
europa
[Music]
clase from fardsworth germany has a
complete blind spot when it comes to its
cars it's got a reputation for being
very progressive when it comes to
climate policy
but when you look at kind of one of the
cornerstones of its economy
building cars that burn fossil fuels
then you see that a lot of it is really
just
spin and i mean they've done it well
but essentially
germany has been very reliable to stand
up to the car lobby
in 2013 the auto industries lobbying
group wrote a pointed letter that
started with the informal greeting liba
angela dear angela
they insisted the chancellor could not
let car makers be regulated to death
they were worried about an eu proposal
to regulate emission standards for cars
mackel slammed the brakes on the
proposal
you remember that german media had
celebrated merkel as the climate
chancellor
now many of them slammed her for
allowing carmakers to wield power money
and influence
but their needs and their contribution
to the german economy cannot simply be
dismissed
something marco's former environment
minister acknowledges
[Music]
is impossible
the biggest trade union in germany says
many auto workers support efforts to
decarbonize the economy but the changes
that will require are triggering deep
uncertainty
it's clearly a juggling act one that got
more difficult when the volkswagen
emissions scandal broke
europe's biggest car maker was rigging
diesel engines to dupe emissions tests
this was a clear case of
cheating cheating
their customers the governments the rest
of the world in effect because this is
about their emissions
and
kind of pretending that their vehicles
were cleaner than they actually were
that cheating had an impact the diesel
emissions scandal appeared to damage
mackel's faith in the auto industry
balancing the power of the car industry
and the pressure to clean up its
emissions put her in a difficult
position
so did another big polluter
coal germany stopped mining hard coal in
2018 but operations like this digging up
lignite or brown coal are not due to
close until 2038.
germany is the world's biggest producer
of brown coal and it's one of the
dirtiest fuels in the world
remember that mackel phased out nuclear
energy that left a gap until renewables
catch up and germany has turned to
fossil fuels like coal in the meantime
brown coal is important in the former
east germany where big lignite mines
provide thousands of jobs but fridays
for future activists say the bigger
picture
is simply far more important
we have some of the largest sources of
co2 within germany
that is our coal mines
we are building more roads even though
this entire country is covered with
roads
we are expanding the car industries and
there is
still complete villages being destroyed
in favor of the
code industries
so it's madness
honestly what is happening in this
country
at home angela merkel the industry
chancellor was battling to protect jobs
and germany's economic success but on
the international circuit she maintained
her image as a visionary climate
chancellor
she played a key role in negotiating the
2015 paris accord when industrialized
nations committed to keep global warming
well below 2 degrees celsius
still the increasing urgency of global
warming would force her into catch-up
mode
2017 saw extreme weather and climate
events come thick and fast devastating
hurricanes in north america alarming
heat waves in europe record wildfires
even in icy greenland global sea levels
reaching new highs
and then one of the world's biggest
emitters the u.s
left the paris climate accord
it was a blow to angela mackel and her
counterparts they did manage to seal a
recommitment to the paris climate
agreement targets that was seen as a
major success but at home there was a
setback
foreign
it was a failure of wealthy nations felt
by climate change campaigners around the
world
so it is a two-way thing that as we
adapt in africa to the climate change
crisis and the global notes of which
germany is one of it is able to mitigate
the impact like we don't we shouldn't
play politics with climate change
because it's going to cause zumos
with pressure growing merkel's cabinet
announced germany's first national
climate law in 2019.
it included measures to get households
and companies to reduce emissions using
a carbon pricing system
the climate law did set targets for
different economic sectors like
transport and industry
but environmentalists and activists
insisted that even with the law the
burden on future generations to cut
emissions was too heavy
their criticism isn't surprising if you
look at the bottom line germany hasn't
reduced its overall emissions enough
since merkel took power
in fact emissions from the transport
sector including the auto industry have
hardly changed at all
people demanding significant change
decided politicians were not helping
climate activists took their arguments
from the streets to the constitutional
court and won
the judges ruled that the burden on
future generations was too high and the
climate law partly unconstitutional
[Music]
the chancellor and her cabinet had to
react they hastily accelerated their
plans pushing forward the deadline to
reach net zero emissions by five years
it was a significant moment showing the
chancellor trying to play catch-up in
her final months in office
critics say she's trying to polish her
climate image but also responding to
increased public awareness of climate
change especially as the effects are
hitting home
climate change marked the start and end
of her time as chancellor so what will
her lasting impact be
putting climate change on the agenda in
her early years
playing to the car industry and powerful
economic forces for too long
or her last flurry of action to put
germany on the path towards net zero
the feds
is
[Music]
[Music]
she has an incredibly mixed record on
climate change on climate policy
and
if you just look at the end numbers if
you just look at the co2 that germany is
admitted to
then
i think that should be the dominant
narrative everyone will be imparted by
the climate change crisis that are rich
or pope so that is why we need to act
now i need to start seeing germany
leading also as one of those developed
countries you know in working they talk
what does mackel herself have to say
what is her scientific analysis of how
she's done
well at her final formal press
conference
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and the crisis is growing the u.n now
says global warming will reach that
critical 1.5 degree threshold far
earlier than previously expected the
climate will affect everything and the
new chancellor will have to build that
into everything she or he does
[Music]
you